Well,
Richard Dawkins is very good at,
at framing science for his audience.
So as an in writing popular science book
books for a worldwide audience of people
who already have a strong interest in
science,
he's been a great translator.
He's discovered the metaphors,
he's discovered.
Uh,
the stories,
the examples that really unlock
complexity for his popular science
audience get,
gets them to understand better the
complexity of evolutionary science when
he's now moved into being an atheist
leader.
He's very good.
And the God delusion at writing for an
audience of atheists,
people already critical religion or
people who are questioning and what he
does a much like bill o'reilly might do
on the O'reilly factor,
he provides talking points and
simplifies the arguments against
religion.
Um,
and connecting how science might be used
as a way to argue against religion.
And people come away from that book with
their preexisting opinions intensified
and also with a lot of talking points to
express their opinion.
So in,
in fact,
he's a social movement leader now he's
mobilized,
he's intensified a movement that's
critical of religion.
But when you move then from his natural
audience out into kind of the swing
public people who appreciate science but
also all maybe moderate real religious,
they attend church.
They have friends and family who are
religious.
They probably lack the motivation and
the interest to actually buy his book.
But they do see Time magazine covers
that say science versus God.
Or they might catch a snippet of one of
the soundbites where he compares
religion to child abuse or religion to
fairies are hobgoblins and he becomes
then the bay.
They're very leading example for
Christian fundamentalist to say,
Hey,
everything we've told you about science
and religion being conflict.
Here's Richard Dawkins is leading
theorists about evolution.
He saying exactly what we've told you is
always been always been true is that
getting evolution in schools is really a
way to undermine religion.
Richard Dawkins actually says,
if you learn about evolution,
you're probably going to be less
religious or evolutionary sciences in
direct conflict with religion.
Um,
and,
and so in that case,
uh,
he can be a polarizing figure.
Uh,
he could actually be used by the other
side to undermine the teaching evolution
in schools,
at least in the United States.
The strongest objections are from what I
call it,
the Richard Dawkins School of
Communication.
Uh,
many of these people are out there in
the blogosphere.
They feel very intensely about the
connection between science and religion.
Uh,
they take the viewpoint that a science
undermines the validity of any religious
belief,
uh,
in fact even respect for religion.
And so their,
their reaction is that,
um,
to say that science and religion are not
in conflict,
uh,
to,
to present evolutionary science in any
way other than just talking about the
facts of the science is not being true
to the science.
It's been,
it's dishonest.
Um,
I've been,
uh,
called at Neville Chamberlain Atheist
Because,
um,
I'm an appeaser of,
of,
uh,
an appeaser and an enabler of people who
really believe in a religion or in God.
Um,
on the other hand,
other scientists have the concern that
this might just translate into spin.
Um,
and that's something that a science
institutions should always be careful
about.
And that's why we always insist when
talking about climate change,
when talking about evolutionary science,
when you package that information in a
way that connects to a non traditional
public,
a non science audience,
you always have to remain true to the
science and in stem cell research,
that's a great example.
In some cases where the reframing of
that issue around social progress,
the ability to lead to cures and
therapies has gone beyond the state of
the science.
The uncertainty with therapies can be
available.
Oftentimes this has been promoted by
politicians such as John Edwards,
who in 2004 said if John Kerry is
elected president,
he was campaigning for Carrie,
for vice president.
Um,
Christopher Reeve would get up out of a
wheelchair and walk again.
Of course this goes well beyond any type
of timeline therapy we might have
available in the foreseeable future.
And that's an example where you can go
beyond the science.
And when you do that,
you risk public trust.
So you always have to be careful.
But certainly no one would ever suggest
that Eo Wilson and writing the creation,
growing the audience for science by
connecting it to,
um,
religious values or the national
academies and doing audience research as
a way to communicate evolution.
No one ever suggest that Eo Wilson of
the National Academies are spinning the
Science.
They're being untruthful about the
science
[inaudible].